hi guys in this video we're gonna talk
about the best nutritional remedies for
psoriasis
okay what is Rice's Sirach is an
autoimmune condition where your own body
has antibodies attacking itself shows up
on the skin as abnormal tissue patches
of red and flamed itchy pili skin okay
but in reality psoriasis is not a skin
problem it's a gut problem it originates
from your gut usually from leaky gut
where there's certain food that goes
through there and in your body develops
antibodies and it creates autoimmune
okay among a lot of other autoimmune
conditions you can get stemming from the
gut so that's what it is that's what
it's caused by now let's talk about what
to do about it
l-glutamine is a natural amino acid it's
a type of protein that is the best
remedy to heal the gut this amino acid
will strengthen the little holes of the
pores or the lining of your gut so it
strengthens the gut lining it feeds the
colon cells okay that's pretty cool and
increases the mucus lining which is the
immune system putting the immune system
back into the gut but there's really two
things you have to know number one the
amount of l-glutamine recommended is way
way way too small the amount recommended
is mainly good for athletes or
bodybuilders that are trying to build
muscle but when you're trying to fix
leaky gut you need a lot more you're
gonna have to take ten grams
three times a day okay some people take
more 10 grams three times a day but I
want you to start off with 10 grams once
a day all right get in a powder because
sometimes the pills come in a thousand
milligrams which is basically one gram
so you have to take ten of those that's
a lot of pills so get it in the powder
it's easier start off with 10 grams once
a day for a couple days and then go take
it twice a day and then take it three
times a day you want to get used to
taking it all right that's number one
number two it must be taken on an empty
stomach
why because these protein
have receptors that can interfere with
other proteins blocking those receptors
so if you take it on an empty stomach
it's just gonna work better all right
so those are the two things take it
between meals right before bed number
two tomato oil what is that that is an
oil that's grown in the tropical south
east part of the world in Asia and this
oil has unique properties of regrowing
skin healing skin and it's wonderful for
psoriasis in fact some people even have
taken it for leprosy so with good
success it has antibacterial properties
it's like a natural antibiotic it has
something called lactone in it so it's
really good for the skin so you can put
it topically all right
third thing vitamin D psoriasis clients
or patients are always deficient in
vitamin D so you want to take that
because vitamin D is very important for
the skin you can get the Sun but if you
take it I would get about 10,000 IU's of
that but you need to take vitamin k2
with it because vitamin k2 and D 3 work
together so both of those are great
combinations so take the mk7 version
I'll put some data down below a hundred
micrograms and then a 10,000 IU's of d3
all right
this combination will greatly improve
your psoriasis put your comments below
hi guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
a report